what do you say you win hey everybody
it's Charlie Netflix and Marvel just
cancelled iron fist and Luke Cage and it
is no coincidence that both of those
shows got cancelled within a week of
each other
iron fist was cancelled last week Luke
Cage was cancelled during the daredevil
season 3 premiere just recently so I'll
explain what's going on there's been a
couple of insider statements about what
happened between Marvel and Netflix
exactly that led to the cancellation
it's not quite as complicated as it
seems but it's a confluence of a couple
different events including budget
creative direction of the show's and
this new Disney streaming service so if
you're new to the channel there's a new
round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video this is the official statement
from Netflix about Luke Cage recently
they say unfortunately Marvel's Luke
Cage will not return for a third season
everyone at Marvel television and
Netflix is grateful to the dedicated
showrunner writers cast and crew who
brought Harlem's hero to life for the
past two seasons and to the fans who
have supported the series same deal for
Iron Fist last week you know thank you
for the support but iron fist will not
continue Marvel has already said that
iron fist the character will continue in
the universe meaning that he'll pop up
on the other shows and cameos and guest
starring spots like he showed up during
Luke Cage for a Heroes for Hire single
episode presumably he would just
continue to do that on which of the
other Netflix shows continue to get new
seasons right now the only new seasons
that we know were confirmed to get our
Punisher season 2 they've finished
shooting that a while ago and Jessica
Jones season 3 they've also finished
shooting that those will air early next
year but the thing is is that because
they've already shot those and there
haven't been any big crossovers already
you're not gonna see those characters
pop up on those next seasons if you saw
Luke Cage and iron fist show up on the
other TV shows it wouldn't be until
daredevil got a fourth season Punisher
got a third season or Jessica Jones got
a fourth season now none of those have
been confirmed Jeph Loeb did say that
there were playing
all ready for daredevil seasons 4 & 5
but Netflix hasn't confirmed that
daredevil has been renewed for season 4
I am crossing my fingers that Netflix
doesn't also cancel daredevil and this
isn't like a bloodbath and then they
just wait till Jessica Jones and
Punisher premiere and then cancel those
TV shows - if this winds up being a
really big line in the sand but here's
the real reason that people have been
talking about why Luke Cage in
particular was cancelled because even
though it might not have brought in the
subscriber numbers that a season of
daredevil might it still was usually
nominated for a lot of awards and there
are only a couple of things that Netflix
cares about they care about bringing in
new subscribers and winning awards so if
your show does one of those two things
really well and it doesn't cost too much
the Netflix will just keep making it for
forever but insiders in this Marvel
Netflix deal have said that the Luke
Cage cancellation was largely because of
creative differences between Netflix and
Marvel over the direction that the story
was taking during Luke Cage season 3 and
the inability to reach terms for a third
season on a business level that means
financially it also means the number of
episodes
remember how iron fist went from the
typical 13 episodes that all the Marvel
series get down to 10 episodes Marvel
gets paid less money if they produce
fewer episodes and you have to imagine
that there are a bunch of lawyers from
Marvel that are trying to make Marvel as
much money as possible regardless of
what the creative story is or the
characters that they're using in Netflix
wants to get that Marvel name they want
to bring in subscribers and pay as
little money as possible if they have to
for it if you don't remember way back
when they first announced the deal for
all four of the Netflix defender shows
and then the defenders team-up it came
at a time when Netflix was desperate for
premium branded content and Marvel
Disney was a huge brand name so they
crazy overpaid for that they bought 13
episodes of all four seasons in bulk
including the defenders on top of that
you're talking hundreds and hundreds of
millions of dollars in Marvel's pocket
so they were really happy about that but
the problem is is that out of all those
seasons only a couple performed really
well brought in a bunch of new
subscribers and then a couple people
just flat-out hated or didn't care about
so now that Netflix is in a more mature
stage of its business cycle they have to
worry about their budget meaning that
they have to act like a normal Network
would so if a show doesn't perform the
way they want it to and it's not headed
in a direction that will make it seem
like it will perform even better they
have to cancel it so a really good
example is that Heroes for Hire episode
that they did during Luke Cage season 2
probably the most watched episode of the
series wouldn't it be awesome if they
just did a Heroes for Hire TV show
[Music]
patty-cake fired up a hit my hands I'm
ready this time the problem is is that
Marvel on their side of things is still
trying to sell 13 episodes of iron fist
and 13 episodes of Luke Cage but if
Netflix wanted Luke Cage to team up with
iron fist and they definitely do they
would have had to pay extra money on top
of the exorbitant fees that they're
already paying to Marvel to produce
those episodes and if those episodes
don't bring in the subscribers that they
want then financially it's not worth it
for them to pay for that so it's mostly
a budget thing when they say creative
differences Netflix is like hey could
you just give us more big Marvel
characters to team up with Luke Cage
let's do that heroes friar Moreau was
like great it's gonna cost you a whole
bunch more money to do that and you know
what we're not gonna give you moon night
we're not gonna give you Ghost Rider or
any new characters because we're gonna
keep them for our Disney streaming
service that we're launching pretty soon
so it's not a really big conspiracy or
anything like that I don't think that
they're secretly going to launch a
Heroes for Hire TV show but I do think
that they're able to do that because the
thing is is that Marvel is obviously
hoarding all of its premium content for
that Disney streaming service that it's
launching they have Tom Hiddleston doing
a low-key TV show based on his movie
character you've never seen a big a-list
movie star do a giant TV show in that
way before
same thing with scarlet witch's TV show
it's gonna be crazy but Netflix still
has the exclusive rights to the shows
that it's already doing it just says
they don't get new characters on top of
that so like Ghost Rider is not going to
appear in any of the Netflix Marvel
series Marvel isn't gonna give that
character up but that does mean because
they still have the characters that they
have right now they could do a team-up
show with Luke Cage and iron fist if
they don't wind up doing it it probably
just comes down to subscriber numbers
like Netflix probably feels like they
get more value just having those
characters cameo on daredevil or a
future season of Jessica Jones so odds
are what'll probably happen is is you'll
see Luke Cage and iron fist do Heroes
for Hire but when they do it'll just be
them showing up for an episode or two
during daredevil season 4 or Jessica
Jones season 4 in
a lot of that's just dependent on
whether or not those episodes perform
well enough in the show's bringing
enough new subscribers because in order
to get both of those big stars to do a
really big action heavy episode like you
would do with the two of them together
it costs way more money to produce than
a normal episode so odds are Heroes for
Hire
really only happens on daredevil because
I don't think that Jessica Jones brings
in the subscriber numbers that daredevil
does so I think odds are pretty good the
week at daredevil season 4 we'll see how
Punisher season 2 performs I don't think
that anybody from the defenders crossed
over to season 2 that'll probably air
sometime March or April next year so
we'll talk more about that when they
start dropping trailers for it they did
not attach any Punisher trailers to the
end of daredevil season 3 so we'll do
more daredevil videos real soon I'm
giving people a chance to watch the
series just leave all your requests in
the comments below and just let me know
what do you want them to do with Iron
Fist and Luke Cage if they don't do a
Heroes for Hire TV show what'll happen
is as Marvel just announced their new
phase 4 movie schedule so I'll do a new
video for that that should post a little
while there's some Titans that I'm
working on too so I'll try to get that
out as fast as possible
I'll leave the Marvel giveaway open til
I post that click here for my breakdown
of that new Avengers 4 trailer and click
here from my non-spoilery daredevil
season 3 review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight